(eerie chiming music)
- Faces are the most important
subject matter in art.
It's a never-ending source of material.
When you put on one of my masks,
you become somebody different.
You start to embody that character,
and have a lot of fun with it.
My name's Landon Meier and I make
disturbingly realistic masks.
(bouncy, playful music)
I never thought I was gonna
make a living doing masks.
I was a picture framer, loan officer,
pizza delivery driver,
and then I got laid off.
I've always been interested
in doing something
that's really surreal and nightmarish.
So, it was more or less an
experiment that took off.
I am the only person
out there that's doing
hyper-realistic likeness masks.
I'm kind of this weird mad scientist
down in the basement.
I start off getting lots
of reference material.
The hardest part is doing the sculpture.
That can take anywhere
from four days to a year,
but once the sculpt is
done and I have a mold,
it's about a one week
process to make a mask.
They are ungodly expensive.
They range $500 and up, and
sometimes even high as $7,500.
Over the years I've made
approximately 25 different designs,
and I've produced with my
own hands over 1,000 masks.
What I make, I like to
consider wearable art.
These are super realistic
sculptures you can
put over your head and wear.
People just seem to have
this astonished reaction
to the masks, that's
what I love about 'em.
(chiming)